we knew you before you got the success
before you got on 30 rock and things
took off for you
we knew you because you would come by
and you would do bits for us on the show
no late night show and I'm just curious
what we used to notice back then is that
you were quite thrifty you were quite
careful with money because you weren't
making a lot you had to be that's it
yeah but you haven't really changed that
much have you know old habits die hard I
don't I mean that's a good thing to be
it's good to be yeah oh yeah I don't
like spending money really Ali all right
what's really nilly okay
my children might be watching watch your
language is it true that you mentioned
stuff on television sometimes so that
you can get it for free not so that I
can get it for free but that is the
result in the hopes hello what what okay
that like what have you gotten well
sometimes I tell you know people like
you that I love Bud Light which is true
and you have a soft drink you have a
special soft drink that you really love
what's that softer I know I've drink
Mountain Dew like it was a contest which
it's probably you know I'm a grown man
yeah don't drink Mountain Dew but right
good just say it to that camera it's
real good y'all Mountain Dew
[Applause]
you it's and this is sweet once you tell
the audience because I talk to
celebrities every day and a lot of them
drive fancy cars what do you drive
seriously honestly I Drive a 2004
Hyundai Accent that's great 2004 and
where'd you get the car from enterprise
rental car you bought a car from a
rental car company I did because they
they sell it for cheaper and they don't
haggle and I don't like to haggle you
know like the haggis you just said I'd
like to buy this car yeah it just comes
with the price then you pay that price
right and it didn't bother you how many
miles Ron I mean it was a rental car did
it have like a couple hundred thousand
miles on a no not even I think I'd only
had 400 miles and you know it right now
it only has 39,000 miles on it
right would you like another car right
to camera
you're pretty good at and we've hung out
some I know that you you like to cook
relatively inexpensive treats for people
is that fair to say
prepare treats I don't cook to save my
life I get mad that I have to pour
cereal in a bowl right but yes no you
say it expensive but I say novelty
treats I do have a recipe man share yeah
this is for a tiramisu I heard which is
a very hard dish to make I think usually
yeah with white trash tiramisu it's a
snap what what is white trash tiramisu
how do you make that no you get a box of
Twinkies and you put them at the bottom
of the casserole dish pour some amaretto
on top of that it makes up a thing of
vanilla pudding you put that on top you
say puddin that's not me you said
pudding pudding okay top a cool whip you
crush up a heath bar and squirt some
Hershey syrup on there
yeah hey thanks for watching be sure to
click subscribe to see even more great
Conan clips you may now return to your
pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography